c'est sûrement une des pires tragédies
qu'une famille plus vivre un enfant de 5
ans qui est dans un état neuro végétatif
irréversible à la suite de noyade
séparant refusent qu'ils soient exubé
mais la Cour d'appel a confirmé hier le
jugement de première instance qui avait
donné raison à l'Hôpital Sainte-Justine
qui recommande de l'extuber alors pour
parler de cette affaire des enjeux
qu'elle soulève en juin maître
Jean-François Leroux il est spécialisé
en droit de la santé en responsabilité
médicale bonjour bonjour alors l'enfant
il est ventilé mécaniquement c'est à
dire qu'on a inséré un tube dans sa
trachée pour l'aider à respirer ça fait
des mois l'hôpital et les parents
s'entendent pour dire qu'il faut tenter
de d'enlever ce tube là mais les parents
veulent qu'on soit prêt à le réintubier
si jamais l'enfant respire pas
d'équatement est-ce que et là c'est là
qu'on a tranché la cour d'appel donne
raison à l'hôpital est-ce que c'est
fréquent ce genre de litige ou les
parents et les soignants se disputent en
cours
heureusement considérant la gravité des
questions qui sont soulevées c'est pas
une situation qui est fréquente et c'est
peut-être justement ce qui génère autant
d'intérêt certainement du côté de la
communauté juridique c'est d'avoir
l'occasion de prendre connaissance donc
d'une décision de la Cour d'appel ou la
cour à l'occasion d'interpréter les
règles qui s'appliquent à des situations
comme celle-là malgré le fait que des
décisions déjà été rendues dans le passé
davantage pour ce qui est d'une
clientèle adulte en matière
d'acharnement thérapeutique c'est disons
une décision qui est assez novatrice là
pour la question qui nous concerne en
première instance le juge avait conclu
que le raisonnement des parents n'est ni
raisonnable ni justifiée parce qu'il
n'envisage le meilleur intérêt de
l'enfant que sous l'angle de son
maintien en vie peu importe sa condition
donc peu importe comment il va ou et
s'il peut se remettre le meilleur
intérêt de l'enfant le mettre le roux
c'est le critère qui doit fonder les
décisions quand on s'attaque à ce genre
de questions là
donc en matière d'autorisation de soins
le meilleur intérêt de la personne visée
est toujours le critère qui s'applique
donc que ce soit pour une clientèle
adulte ou pour une clientèle pédiatrique
donc en cas de majeur inapte par exemple
c'est la même critère qui va s'appliquer
et c'est vraiment la question de la cour
d'appel devient intéressante en ce sens
ce qu'elle nous dit c'est que le
maintien de la vie à tout prix n'est pas
nécessairement un synonyme du meilleur
intérêt de l'enfant alors justement
comment on fait pour évaluer comment la
cour évalue ça le meilleur intérêt d'un
enfant on doit faire une preuve médicale
pour nous dire que si il est maintenu en
vie il y aura pas de qualité de vie
c'est comme ça qu'on détermine ça un
intérêt
alors le Code civil nous guide un peu
donc on retrouve au code civil 3
critères qui vont nous permettre de
définir en quoi consiste le meilleur
intérêt donc SS seulement parce que
sinon à savoir si les soins sont
bénéfiques si les soins sont opportuns
et si les risques sont associés au
traitement sont pas hors de proportion
finalement avec les bénéfices qu'on peut
escompter alors c'est quand même des
définitions qui sont un petit peu
laconiques et large donc on doit
regarder un peu plus près la chaque
situation actuelle à l'aide d'une preuve
d'expert ici la cour d'appel insiste
beaucoup sur la qualité de la preuve qui
a été administrée en première instance
alors que quatre experts un médecin ont
eu l'occasion d'être entendus donc que
ce soit des pédiatres intensives des
neurologues et la preuve elle était
uneanime d'abord quant aux pronostics
sombres de l'enfant mais aussi et
surtout quand on risque associer au
maintien donc de l'incubation alors on
parlait entre autres de risques accru de
développer par exemple des pneumonies ou
encore de développer des plats de
pression combinées au fait que l'enfant
pouvait pas nécessaire bénéficie d'une
manière thérapie ou d'un autre milieu de
vie que le milieu hospitalier alors
c'est un soupesant l'ensemble de ces
critères là toujours en étant guidé par
les experts que la Cour d'appel nous dit
finalement que le juge de première
instance avait raison bon dans ce cas-ci
il y a des valeurs il y a des croyances
qui entrent en ligne de compte et je me
suis demandé les croyances religieuses
des parents ça peut pas justifier leur
décision on prend pas en la liberté de
religion disons elle n'a pas prisé dans
ce genre de dossier là
c'est certainement un point qui peut
être évoqué ou discuter devant les
tribunaux c'est pas une question qui est
non pertinente mais lorsque vient le
temps de soupeser maintenant l'influence
de l'un et de l'autre les tribunaux
accorde très très peu d'importance à ces
croyants en ces croyances là en matière
d'autorisation de soins il existe
d'ailleurs une jurisprudence constante
en matière de transfusion sanguine par
exemple et la clientèle donc des
croyances de Témoins de Jéhovah ou
constamment les croyances religieuses ne
sont pas considérées comme un facteur
pour déterminer le meilleur intérêt ici
c'est pas nécessairement énormément
discuté dans le jugement même si on a
l'impression que c'est peut-être en
arrière-plan mais à la fin de la journée
considérant donc le poids de la preuve
d'expert qui a été présenté du côté de
l'hôpital alors qu'il y avait pas
nécessairement une preuve équivalente du
côté de des parents la décision
allait de soi je pense dans ce
contexte-là le premier juge avait
apporté d'ailleurs une quelques
modifications plein de traitements qui
avaient été proposé par l'équipe
soignante est-ce que ça arrive souvent
ce qu'un tribunal singer dans un plan de
traitement c'est effectivement des
choses qu'on voit sur une base régulière
alors évidemment la décision est
passablement unique mais à une autre
échelle on fait beaucoup d'autorisation
soin par exemple en matière
psychiatrique et très souvent au moment
de l'audition on va assister à une
discussion entre le jeu et par exemple
les témoins experts sur les bénéfices
les inconvénients de différents
traitements et en cours d'audition
parfois les témoins vont venir admettre
certains certaines faiblesses peut-être
du prendre soin les juges ont souvent
une certaine expérience aussi de ces
causes là ils vont venir guider puis
rectifier le dire pour s'assurer autant
que possible que le plan de traitement
qui est déterminé va non seulement dans
le meilleur intérêt du patient qui est
visé mais qui sont aussi conforme et le
moins attentats possible au droit
fondamentaux de l'usager alors lorsqu'on
il nous reste très peu de temps mais la
Cour dit que ça comportait pas d'erreur
la première décision mais qu'est-ce qui
aurait fallu pour que la Cour d'appel
intervienne en même temps en 10 secondes
alors la Cour aurait pu intervenir donc
en présence d'une erreur de fait
manifeste ou en présence d'une erreur de
droit et considérant la preuve qui a été
administrée la cour d'appel nous dit
qu'il y avait aucune de ces erreurs là
qui était présente qui justifiait
d'intervenir donc de la décision merci
infiniment de mettre le rouge c'est
extrêmement clair merci beaucoup pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez-vous
sur la chaîne ici RDI